I'm close
okay
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 149 which I'm
told is prime but it doesn't feel like
it should be really doesn't feel Prime
yeah and that's what mine yeah
um but I'm 49 divisible by seven right
no it just feels on Prime yes we are we
are united and not divided over the
divisibility of 149. in any case I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
there was a false start to this podcast
with a technical difficulty with one of
the microphones and as a result of that
we are going to clip this one we're
starting here brand new which means that
our scintillating discussion of sticker
adhesives is going to be lost to history
it's an Easter egg for those of you who
care enough about Dark Horse to watch
live and so anyway
um indeed no we're not going to repeat
that here you missed it if you missed it
you missed it that's right and so you
will never know you will forever wonder
what what is causing 11 of the misery in
the Western World you won't know you
won't know but those who watched no
yeah I was going to say next time be on
time but I we are hardly in a position
to say that apologies
I think that here we are in our new
permanent temporary permanent temporary
permanent Studio did I get that right
it's permanent temporary I believe it's
not it's not a b a b a I thought it was
a permanent temporary permanent
temporary permanent if we're going to be
switching to I am victim iambic
pentameter I I needed to know that a
half an hour ago I don't know
so you need lead time for a Hamburg
pentameters really I don't think uh
specifying a b a b a whatever is
inherent it's not inherently either
iambic or pentameter no or pentametric
it seem like the direction you were
going I might be construe you know look
I'm no fan of free verse I know but for
podcasts you kind of have to go with it
well riffing yes riffing is is pretty
free totally yes yes sometimes you get
into a rhythm but uh anyway here we are
you get on a roll
yeah
yeah
all right I I don't know I didn't get it
that reminds me of that moment in Flight
of the Conchords but uh anyway I digress
I guess what Moment In Flight of the
Congress there's a point at which uh one
of the dudes I forget which one it is is
uh rapping and he claims his Rhymes are
bottomless and then he's got nothing
excellent he's he's the hippopotamus
yes yes what a weird show
yes Flight of the Concords con course
chords for those of you who haven't
heard of this show yeah it's a great one
yeah uh all right so here we are uh it
is uh Dark Horse live stream of 149 here
with our technical difficulties and our
almost snoring dog and uh and there's a
lot to talk about yes but first some
some business we follow these live
streams with a live q a you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
if you're watching on YouTube the chat
is live on Odyssey and uh very soon
after we are done uh the as as we've
already talked about the video will be
clipped we'll go we'll put it on Spotify
as well and we will um also be on all
the podcast places so you can listen
anywhere that you listen to podcasts uh
please join me also every week at
Natural Selections which is where I
write weekly on my substant natural
selections.substep.com this week I did
something that I talked about on Dark
Horse last week which is that I
transcribed a piece of an episode that
we did in January of this year I think
it was episode 112. I don't remember
anyway I talk about Natural Selections
in which
we predicted that some among those who
were crying for vaccine mandates and uh
being very uh laughing at laughing at
and harming those of us who were
resisting the authoritarian and
anti-scientific uh advice and
uh and demands that were coming down
from on high Public Health on high we
predicted that they would soon basically
try to disappear their their sins and
indeed what we saw last week or a week
and a half ago at this point was a piece
by Emily Oster in the Atlantic asking
for amnesty so I transcribed for Natural
Selections this week a a piece out of
our discussion from now almost 10 months
ago in which we said this is going to
happen and we can't I actually I I
recommend it I recommend that they're
going back to the conversation itself or
looking at the looking at the transcript
because we don't arrive at exactly the
same place we don't start exactly the
same place we don't arrive at exactly
the same place but
um we do both a mightily object to the
idea that this should just be passed
and disappear into history without
anyone learning anything and without any
therefore assurances that it won't
happen again and soon and perhaps worse
yeah I read the the transcript that you
did and uh I think it is it's important
not only to see that it was predicted
and that it is unfolding but to
understand why it was predictable that
there's a Confluence between the
interests of those uh you know members
of the private sector who got it wrong
listen to the wrong authorities and
those who actually uh perpetrated this
monstrosity of policy that they have a
shared interest in essentially finding
new voices to slap those in power on the
wrist
rather than to have a full accounting
that says how the hell did this happen
and how can we prevent it from happening
again and so anyway uh we call about the
middle ground scramble and um it is it
is a foot
um so anyway yeah I recommend people go
back and look at your your sub stack on
it wonderful
okay we also have a fantastic new store
as I mentioned uh last week and Zach you
can show you could show our newest
product here no worries I just want to
talk about the store a little bit it is
uh run not only the store but also the
print shop associated with the store so
the online store and the print shop
that's actually produced in the
merchandise are run by a couple right
here in the United States they are
amazing and the product quality is
much higher and consistently higher than
it could be when we were working with uh
with with Teespring so we encourage you
to go there any chance you can make that
any bigger so this is the newest product
a couple weeks ago we introduced do not
affirm do not comply and this is lie to
a tyrant which was generated it was
inspired by Brett ending a live stream a
few weeks back by saying lie to a tyrant
and so here we have that's just really
hard to see but anyway the artwork is
fabulous go take a look and uh and this
is this is I'm very pleased with this
this is great and there's a whole lot of
stuff there as well
so that's at darkhorsestore.org
and we are of course supported by you we
are grateful for you we appreciate you
subscribing liking sharing both our full
episodes and uh any clips that are
generated uh at Darkhorse podcast Clips
on both YouTube and odyssey and YouTube
is putting ads on our stuff but they
demonetized us fully so they and only
they are making money from the ads that
they put on our things so if you uh if
you're in a position to and um and feel
like it we encourage you to join one of
our patreons where you get access to
private monthly q and A's which are a
lot of fun intimate conversations with
Brett and also access to the Discord
server where you can engage in honest
conversations about difficult topics
join a book club unwind with virtual
happy hours and karaoke young or old
left or right there's a spot for you at
the campfire
and of course we have sponsors so the
ads that we're about to read which will
be introduced with a sound and um and
what's the opposite of introduced uh
outtroduced outroduced would be the
modern that trailed by yeah finished by
anyway yes there's a little sound at the
beginning in the end of the ads and
whenever we are reading ads for those of
you watching there's a green perimeter
on the screen so that's where you know
when we are actually reading sponsored
content nothing else in our show ever is
that said we choose our sponsors very
very carefully we don't read ads for
products or services that we don't
actually vouch for so with that said let
us proceed with the three ads for today
anywhere first all right we are thrilled
to have Western Razer companies
sponsoring Darkhorse
and I particular in particular am
thrilled uh I want to tell you why my
grandfather Harry was a chemist he
worked on vinyl for long playing records
at RCA he worked on Dental polymers and
he worked at Schick safety razor comedy
that's what he called it normal people
just call it Schick at least now but in
any case when I uh was young and I would
visit him I would look at the Razer
prototypes that he had kept and these
safety razors weren't at all like modern
razors they were Hefty durable serious
objects built to last so these are like
from the 40s or 50s
wow boy I don't remember you visited him
in the 70s and they were at that point
historically I think it would have been
the 50s but it could have been okay it
could have been earlier
um years later when I began shaving I
forgot all about those old razors the
world was by then full of colorful
up-to-date options with pivoting heads
lubricating strips and multiple blades
he's in progress Grand
decades later I've come full circle it's
true that modern razors are better
better at getting you to spend a lot
more than necessary on shaving pivoting
heads that's a gimmick you are supposed
to adjust the angle of the razor for the
Contours of your face not have the razor
follow the path of least resistance if
it doesn't that take skill uh yes you do
have to learn a little does that take
attention shouldn't you be able to not
pay any attention when you have a blade
near your neck oh shaving without paying
attention is not a winning strategy
um all right let's talk about
lubrication strips no no it's okay it's
all of the good lubrication strips they
work at first but they exhaust
themselves quickly leading you to toss a
razor that still has life left in the
blades and speaking of blades how many
do you really need
the fact is that multiple blades pack
tightly together is just another scam
that Arrangement is guaranteed to clog
with hair and soap so you'll toss it in
the garbage and reach for another
also seems more likely that one of them
is going to need a little a little Nick
in it and therefore be more likely to
cut you you can just look at the thing
you know there's a principle in aviation
if it doesn't look right it won't fly
right and you can look at these
multi-blade monstrosities and you just
know that that's not an elegant solution
to any known problem
so I need to try these yes you do yeah
if you want a close shave then what you
need is a no-nonsense shaving instrument
a safety razor from Western Razor
Company looks like a tool it feels like
a tool and it functions like a tool
because that's what it is no plastic no
gimmicks no hidden costs no
subscriptions you pay up front for a top
quality handle made entirely here in the
U.S it comes with five double-sided
blades and when you need more top
quality blades double-sided razor blades
are available for less than 20 cents a
piece point of order that's awesome it
comes with five double-sided blades but
you only use one at a time
use one side at a time unless two of you
are going to shave very closely so it
comes with 10
10 blade surfaces yes it does but these
things are so it's beautifully made very
inexplan inexpensive uh refills for
these things
all right so what do you do you go to
westernrazor.com Darkhorse and use the
promo code Darkhorse to support the
podcast and get 10 off your order and
take a stand against the propaganda
Stranglehold of big shaving again that's
westernrazor.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse at checkout awesome
all right our second ad sponsor today is
element it's l-m-n-t
element is an electrolyte drink mix that
is everything you need and nothing you
don't it's got a lot of salt a thousand
milligrams of sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 of magnesium it has no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten and no fillers
electrolytes facilitate hundreds of
functions in the body including the
conduction of nerve impulses hormonal
regulation and nutrient absorption
elements electrolytes can help prevent
and eliminate headaches muscle cramps
and sleeplessness
we have now heard from several friends
about how much they like element for
themselves or in some cases for the
physically hard-working men in their
lives they drink it every day and feel
better doing so
When you sweat the primary electrolyte
lost is sodium athletes can lose up to 7
grams per day element is formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
not just athletes and is perfectly
suited to folks following a keto low
carb or Paleo Diet
element is as I said not just for
athletes anyone being active may find
that they benefit from element even
drinking a few glasses of wine can leave
you depleted an element can help if
you're feeling depleted or dehydrated
drink water and consider element as well
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight flavors
or share element with a salty print and
I will say some of the flavors not to my
liking some of them are quite good so
you probably want to try them and see
which ones work for you and which ones
you can Pawn off on your salty friends
get yours at drinkelement.com Darkhorse
this deal is only available through our
link you must go to Dr
inklmnt.com Darkhorse
to get your free eight samples and
figure out which ones you love element
offers no questions asked refunds try it
totally risk-free if you don't like it
share it with again that salty friend of
yours and they will give you your money
back not the salty friend element will
give you your money back if you don't
like it no questions asked you have
nothing to lose you're salty and
well-heeled friends might give you your
money back just
just to get rid of you right exactly
okay our final sponsor this week is
relief band
a product that can help with nausea in
ancient times nausea was a signal that
something was off and that signal was
useful nausea was telling you that you
had eaten something you shouldn't have
or were near something emanating a bad
smell itself a signal that you should
not go near it
in modernity we still need to track our
bodily sensitivities we should not
always choose to erase discomfort like
nausea when we feel it but some aspects
of modernity create nausea that does no
good at all travel sickness for instance
can be agonizing and relief would be
lovely
enter relief band relief band is an
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to relieve and prevent
nausea associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines chemotherapy and more
relief man is 100 drug free and can be
used for as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago it was the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting and there are zero side effects
and now there's relief fan support which
is waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has extended battery life
we asked a friend to try it out since we
are lucky enough to barely experience
nausea ourselves here is her testimonial
I used to have nausea on a near near
daily basis from both anxiety and the
need to take regular medication relief
band relieves my nausea in less than
three minutes without the side effects I
was experiencing from anti-nausea
medication it has entirely changed my
life for the better so if you've got
nausea from anxiety or car or
seasickness or something else that you
cannot otherwise disable consider relief
band relief band makes a great gift for
any time of year right now they've got
an exclusive offer just for Dark Horse
listeners go to reliefband.com and use
promo code Darkhorse to receive 20 off
plus free shipping and a no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee that's
reliefband.com and use our promo code
Darkhorse for 20 off plus free shipping
all right
here we are
um my computer has gone to sleep I hope
you have nots
uh at the point that you bore your
computer into oh man I've been there
running on too long yep possible okay
um
can we start by talking about certainty
I think so
excellent
I was in Portland this week I went back
to the city that we called home for four
years
uh in part to see some of the amazing
medical providers that I have formed
relationships without with down there
and yes they do exist
and in part the timing was uh to be
there for the election to see to see
what it felt like and to see if anything
blew up
um
and I think we'll talk a bit about a lot
of these things and I think my substate
this next week is going to be talking a
bit about what I saw in Portland
um I don't I don't have it
in a sound bite or even a series of
sound bites yet there's just there's a
lot to say about what that City with so
much potential is and has and what it's
doing uh
but one of the things that I did while I
was there was I met with
um just a wonderful woman uh who I'm not
going to name her I failed to ask if I
could
um but I know she watches Dark Horse and
she is finding herself
angry
and in talking Angry that so many among
her circle of oldest friends and some
among her family
are responding to her like she's the
problem
and for
for
not vaccinating her children
for not wearing a mask when she's
outside
for not trusting the public health
officials that we know have been lying
to us now for a long time
and not trusting the next thing that
comes out of their mouths
for this she is being told that she is
wrong and
I began to say yeah they judge us don't
they and I realized in this this
conversation I have with her no we're
all judging each other now we are all
judging each other we are
we seem to be so many of us increasingly
certain
of our positions
and I then I also saw a piece of theater
in Portland
that put this into very sharp relief
in which a person who has simply adopted
it was a it was a one-woman show
a person who is simply adopted
all of the narratives from the
mainstream and the public health
apparatus
as
as the truth as the only truth
as the forever truth
has said
I was watching her certainty and thought
well okay how is her certainty how are
the people in our Lives who are angry
with us for making these decisions that
we feel more and more certain were the
right ones how is there certainty
different from our certainty
and one of the things I arrived at was
we didn't start out certain
we started out skeptical
unhesitant and employing the
precautionary principle
with things like
where's this virus from
what might it do
how's it going to proceed
let's use the wisdom that we do have as
for instance evolutionary biologists as
bat biologists as people with a history
of thinking about granting agencies
and figure out what we think might be
true and figure out what the predictions
of those ideas would be and let's see
what happens
and when for instance the code vaccines
were beginning to be rolled out and we
were told they're safe they're 100 safe
there are a lot of us who said
you've just lied to us
not because we didn't not because we
knew that they weren't 100 safe because
we didn't
but because we knew that they couldn't
know no no you got to be careful about
that they could not be 100 safe if they
didn't know whether or not they did harm
they could have been 100 harmless
but the safety comes from knowing that
they do know I maybe this is important
it doesn't strike me as important at the
moment
um that that distinction
um and I think that's going to muddle
the issue here because this is a very
important issue and I I think you're
going to have to let me not go down that
semantic road for the moment and you can
you can do the certification that you
think you need to afterwards
our objections not just us but so many
people
so many people's objections people with
scientific training people without
scientific training people in all lines
of work
at the point that a new medical
treatment is brought to Market and we
are told they're 100 safe what we know
for sure is you can't know that
there hasn't been time
we are uncertain we were at that point
uncertain we in fact figured we assumed
we're going to wait as long as possible
and then we'll get them because we're
gonna
we will get them probably right and then
weeks past and months passed and more
and more evidence
did become public and it became clear
clearer and clearer that actually I'm
not safe
not effective
by contrast the people who
were certain in the other direction
started out that way
they were told by people who were not
telling them the truth these are safe
and effective and they said ah they're
safe and effective and anyone who says
differently is a conspiracy theorist and
anti-factor or whatever
and so
the prediction I want to make
which is maybe maybe prediction isn't
even exactly the right word here but the
prediction I want to make is that even
though I at this point
have a high degree of certainty that for
instance the coveted vaccines are
neither safe nor effective
I did not start out that way
and I think that the of the if if you
take the the two camps such as it is
over in coveted vaccine territory
uh the what is wrong with you people why
are you putting us all In Harm's Way
take the damn vaccine crowd
and the absolutely not I'm not going to
do it and what are you doing to your
children crowd
at the moment the people in these crowds
seem to have similar levels of certainty
with opposite valences but the
prediction is that the people over there
are some people over in the I'm not
getting your damn vaccine crowd who
started out that way and they were also
being non-scientific in their approach
right
but there
my prediction is that there are more
people over in the I'm not taking that
treatment crowd who started out
uncertain and skeptical and hesitant on
using the precautionary principle and
using science and as more and more
evidence came in developed a higher
degree of certainty because that's what
science does for you
and that by contrast the people over
here who
started out certain that they that this
was going to be the thing that ended the
pandemic
have changed in no way in their
certainty even as evidence has arrived
in abundance to the contrary that their
cert their degree of certainty has not
changed and when you see anyone with a
position whose degree of certainty has
not changed you know they are not
thinking logically you know they are not
thinking scientifically and you know
that for all of their talk about nuance
and being following the science and all
that they are wrong whether or not
they're deceiving themselves or just
deceiving you I don't know it doesn't
matter but they are wrong
all right several things to say about
this one I want to point out that there
are two instances in which I know myself
to have visibly changed my position in a
way that you could even go back and
check in in this pandemic in the context
of the pandemic one of them is at the
very start the following thing can be
found on Twitter
you and I as we've talked about before
did not know about the novel coronavirus
until we emerged from finishing the
first draft of our book where we were
deep in the Amazon where we had no
connectivity unaware that there was a
new story Brewing as we emerge to the
first place that your phone connects a
military checkpoint end of January 2020.
yep we emerged to news we were in
Ecuador we emerged news that there was
this novel coronavirus which we started
to wrap our minds around and oddly that
the first case had just arrived in
Ecuador so we're getting information on
our phone in Spanish new case novel
coronavirus from China
Etc
um
as I looked into it story was this was a
bat virus that had jumped to humans I
knew something about the family of bats
in question because I had been a bat
researcher
and I tweeted something that said I
haven't looked very deeply into this
story but so far it seems to check out
right I know these animals I know
something about these viruses
circulating in these animals it looks
right to me and I got back a tweet from
an account that uh I knew only online
and the account said something like yeah
right it's a coincidence that this
happened in you know uh in a city that
had a a level four
um biosafety level for lab studying
these exact viruses
and I looked at that and I thought what
don't I know
what the hell that is a weird
coincidence
that thought what don't I know
anyone who doesn't ask themselves that
question on the regular is also not
trustworthy right thing is so I
retracted my claim that this story made
sense I didn't yet know what made sense
but I knew at that point that there was
something here that I had not factored
into my calculation so whatever I had
said publicly didn't make any sense and
you know it could have been that it was
uh that the story did check out and that
the existence of the laboratory in Wuhan
was a coincidence
um you know which I guess I would have
figured out over time but the point is I
believe the two tweets are separated
just by accident by exactly an hour
right that the whole thing the
recognition that I had said something
that I now knew was not grounded because
it missed the whole set of facts that
were potentially relevant that's
captured in the space of exactly one
hour in that case and it could have been
an hour a day a week a month a year it
could have been anything it could have
been anything but the point is you went
back and you said ah my level of
certainty was too high and as it turns
out the wrong valence right right and so
anyway this is I mean and you know it
makes I remember my emotional state that
I like saying hey I said something
scientifically about something in my own
discipline and now you know an hour
later I've got to take it back do I like
that no but it's far better far better
than sticking with a wrong idea because
it would be embarrassing to admit that
it was wrong you know well there's a
sunk costs fallacy there too right that
you did not succumb to but that most
people do well I've already done the
thing I've already like this is it's
like maybe it's not maybe that's not
quite the right fallacy there's a like I
don't there's a good one it's good money
after bad okay that's that's it so I
don't oh this is going to be bad for
this is gonna feel really uncomfortable
the longer you wait the worse it gets
guys well you know and I think
the thing that is important not to have
done right one could do the calculation
and say well
okay
I've just learned something I didn't
know it changes my private certainty
about how
sensible the story that I've heard is
but it's possible that the story
that I believe is correct is still going
to turn out to be correct so if I can
just does it notic origin yeah if I can
just put off making a correction then
it's possible the problem solves itself
right that's not that is a way to get
yourself in trouble which is why I
didn't do that right the right thing to
do is to say actually as of now I'm
aware that even if the natural origin
story turns out to be right that it has
to overcome a threshold that I didn't
even realize existed because I didn't
know that that lab was there
that's just so beautiful that like that
right there that is an encapsulation of
both what you do
and what all scientists should do and
what everyone should do in communicating
with the world having made a statement
and Having learned that there's more
to the thing that you pronounced upon
with such certainty
be like brats like do that well you'll
also you'll be you'll just be happier
right because the fact is the relief
that you experience for having gotten
yourself back to ground you're
comfortable with right the point is
you're actually taking a risk saying
yeah I've looked at this paper seems to
add up thing emerged from
bats you know in some normal way right
and then it's like oh goodness what what
didn't I know right there's a fact I
didn't have and then the point is that
the point you say publicly uh actually
this fact potentially looks important I
need to know more about it then it's not
haunting you it's not lurking waiting to
LEAP out you know you're not you know
constantly keeping track of how much
danger this thing you said is leaving
you in so anyway just even just from the
point of view of your own sanity it's an
honest accounting it's an honest
accounting that means that in the
present you don't have to worry about
saying too much or something like that
and that's not to say so I mean I think
I a different approach the approach that
I have tended to take is I don't like
and you know until relatively recently
this is 100 like I just don't make
pronouncements out into the world until
I've actually you know I'm really
prepared to do it because I don't want
to have to keep track of all of the
things that I've said that I then would
do have to actually go and and correct
when you know when when I'm wrong and
obviously podcasting changes that
Dynamic quite a lot but I was thinking
specifically of social media like I
actually I there is just there was such
a joy and like a human potential in
sitting in uncertainty and being like oh
this thing is happening
I don't know what it means I don't know
what the significance is I don't know
where it came from I don't know what
it's going to do
and yet we
in the following two months we're having
these conversations around our dinner
table every day and we're like you know
I think actually these conversations
that we're having are worth sharing and
that was actually what began the live
streams I began to say to you as you
know our boys schools were being shut
down it's like we actually have things
to share and we weren't right about
everything early on at all by any means
right but we were having conversations
by which
we were we were demonstrating how you
might figure out what is true and that's
the thing is it's not like were you
right it's like do you have a process
for becoming right the process for
becoming right involves the uncertainty
it involves saying things that turn out
to be wrong discovering that they are
wrong being honest with yourself and
others about it that's that's the
process and you know science formalizes
a piece of this but nonetheless it's
it's obviously the right thing to do now
if if I think back I remember exactly
where we were during this one hour
uh
wobble between perspectives here and I
remember I think my thought process why
did I weigh in on a story that was so
new right why not just hold off and see
and I believe that my thought process
was
how many bat biologists does the world
know
right not that many I studied under
actually one who became quite famous she
now tragically died very early in the
field Elizabeth calco who uh you know
you you have probably heard that XI jang
li was called the Batwoman because she
studied bats in China well no the real
bat woman was Elizabeth calco and she
was a force to be reckoned with
um but anyway
the point is the world does not know
very many bad biologists I happen to be
a bat biologist with hundreds of
thousands of Twitter followers and I
felt an obligation to say something
precisely because I didn't want
conspiracy uh uh undisciplined
conspiracy thoughts to emerge from this
people who showed up certain on the
other side without any evidence right
right certainty at the beginning of
anything like this is is a tell yeah
you're not thinking carefully are you
trying to sell me something are you just
confused at some level it doesn't matter
you're not thinking carefully right so
what I said was effectively
you know this isn't my story I don't
have a dog in this fight but I do know
the bats right I know that these viruses
circulate amongst them the story I see
written here makes sense to me right and
that basically says look on a first pass
this is a plausible story
wasn't the plausible story it turns out
right and the process of discovery that
led there
um you know does involve a willingness
to be uncertain including in the first
you know hour after you've said what you
thought was a I mean I didn't say
anything you didn't say the story is
true yeah I said think it checked out it
looks sex superficially looks right
um
the other place where uh my wrong
initial perspective is absolutely
captured
is masks
of which as you know I was we talked a
lot about masculine we talked a lot
about Mass I was very early on
um using masks and advocating for them I
you made me so grumpy
I did not want to go into stores mask
early on and you're like it's the thing
and I I came around and then we both
came around the other way yep but and
you know I look I you know I had a model
in my head and I remember I talked about
it I showed it uh on Dark Horse in which
the idea was well how much I can use my
camera to tell me how much light is
blocked by a bandana
and it's a fair amount and
um that to me suggested the likelihood
that particles would be blocked and you
can say well particles are too tiny they
go through the holes apparently they do
but photons are also very tiny what
photons don't do is you know there's no
flow pattern around a fiber right the
photon hits the fiber or it doesn't it
doesn't you know Steer around it whereas
air flowing over probably brings the
particles through the mask which is
probably why they don't work very well
excuse me but the following thing also
occurs to me in hearing uh your
description here
which is that we had this recent you
know you say we're all judging each
other and I think this is this is true I
think we might know that when I see
people wearing masks I have a thought
that I can't stop especially when I see
them wearing masks outside right it's
like okay how what what model is running
around in your head you know years into
this that you still think it makes sense
for you to mask yourself Outdoors but
I'm going to say here's something to you
that you often say to me while I'm
trying to figure out what is going on in
their heads and you say it's not like
that like very often and I I assume that
in some cases it is a model and it's
just a bad model but very often it's not
a model and this is this is to my point
about they arrived at the certainty upon
being told a thing and it doesn't get
updated it's not a model it's not a
complex living thing it's a conclusion
end of story done
right now this is exactly this is
exactly where I'm headed is that you and
I had the following uh
episode in our in our own life a minor
thing but you and I uh had an
appointment with somebody
and I can't remember which one of us had
come down with a slight respiratory
something you know a little cold that
under ordinary pre-coveted circumstances
would not be worth even mentioning it
just would be like oh that's annoying
um
but
we were going to meet with this person
and in light of covid for the first time
this wasn't someone we knew before right
yep I felt it was necessary to warn her
and to give her the option to cancel the
meeting in case this was covered right
and she suggested quite rightly how
about you wear a mask and I said how
about we don't wear masks and we meet
outside and when we go inside to look at
the samples or whatever it was that we
needed to see that then we will put on a
mask but then two in fact we didn't
share a mask no we had two entirely
different masks um but
I remember having the weird thought like
I do not want
the cost of being seen to wear a mask
which implies either a simplistic and
wrong model of covid or no model at all
as you point out is likely going on with
many of these people and so it was like
actually the fact that I don't wear a
mask I certainly don't wear a mask
Outdoors but in this case I was going to
put on a mask right now that becomes
complex it's actually evidence that
pattern if you saw you know hour after
hour of not wearing a mask and then you
know slight respiratory something and
because I'm the person who might be
spreading whatever it is wearing a mask
makes more sense
um you know that's evidence of a nuanced
model it's not evidence of the absence
of a model but because masks are
something that we now judge each other
for because of the way that they have
been politicized
um
it was it was a tough calculation that
shouldn't have been yeah the right thing
to do was to say look there's very
little harm in it in this case it's not
I'm not committing to wear a mask you
know in general it just it happens
as a courtesy it made sense yeah
um
last thing I wanted to say from your
initial intro here is I think the
failure you're talking about
is
extremely
um clear and consequential with respect
to the doctors
and I suspect that we can learn
something about how civilization goes
crazy that your point about certainty
where are the doctors now right I don't
think you could be a working
cardiologist or pathologist or
oncologist
or coroner
and not be aware of the huge harm that
we inflicted on ourselves I'm not
talking about code but I'm talking about
vaccine Adverse Events
um I don't think you could be unaware
and so where is the chorus of these
doctors who got it wrong initially and
have now realized that and are standing
up and saying you know it's throughout
my Cardiology Ward it's you can't miss
it right where are those doctors well
there are a couple but it's not a chorus
of them and most
among the you know it's more than a
handful but relative to the core of
doctors it's a handful it's a tiny
fraction of doctors most of them don't
have Wards anymore right they've been
relieved of Duty oh that's not what I'm
talking about you're right that's a tiny
number the dissidents came out who
initially said hey wait a second what
I'm seeing it doesn't add up what the
claims don't add up I'm seeing stuff
that's not being discussed there's a
system that catches these Adverse Events
we're not monitoring it those doctors
stood up and it was a handful and they
largely and are continuing to lose their
positions their editorships
Etc
um I'm talking about doctors who
presumably did what they thought was
right at the beginning said what they
thought was true at the beginning now
have incontrovertible evidence in front
of them and are not standing up now
that's the thing and there are a couple
who have right there are a couple
um some of them have gone halfway which
confuses me once you've seen what this
what's the halfway what's a halfway
position oh a halfway position is uh yes
these Adverse Events are very serious
but there is no uh early treatment
option you know there are no repurposed
drugs that are worth
consideration so the vaccines are still
the right choice or uh in some cases in
some cases you get a partial like you
know for many people they don't make
sense but which I don't think is true
yeah anymore well I mean most most
scientific articles about anything
having to do with uh with vaccine
Adverse Events still have to start I
mean it's you could just see the like
Guillotine over these guys the
researchers heads like you you were told
by the editor of the journal that you
were not able to put you were not going
to be allowed to publish any results
that in any way show Adverse Events
unless you basically bracket your
article with yeah but they're awesome
still it's the best way to avoid kovid
yep and I mean I think actually bmj uh
British medical journal is a very
interesting exception that's emerging
the editor of bmj turns out to be I
think the reason that we've seen so many
interesting op-eds and some research
being published there and only there
among the major journals right and which
tells you something the the
arbitrariness of you have some journal
in which author after author is saying
the same thing and the point is well you
know under a different editor but that
journal have a radically different
perspective even with the same pool of
readership and researchers who use that
journal editors are powerful not just
you know it's not just for literature
right it's this is the scientific
there's a reason they call it the
scientific literature because there is
someone who is effectively not just
it's not
you know if I want to go here but
become sort of Midwife gets applied in a
lot of places where it has no place yeah
and it's you know like how could you
object to Midwife it's like no actually
sometimes what you're doing is helping
create and midwives don't help create
the baby they help ensure that a baby
ends up in the world that was inside a
mother's body and is safe in the world
but the Midwife did not help create the
baby and so editors are doing more than
midwifing oh yeah by a lot and uh and I
think especially in the scientific realm
those who aren't in science have this
very strange cartoonish version of how
it is that we come to know what we come
to know and that's part of why you can
get things like hashtag follow the
science people like oh okay I'll follow
the science I guess so that was handed
down by science God yeah and you know
it's exactly that kind of cartoonish
Vision so yes if the editor of a journal
changes can the can the journal change
its direction absolutely oh absolutely
and you know and means you know what is
the Atlantic today right it's not a
scientific journal it under any
circumstances but the point is that that
used to be an important publication in
which things were hashed out and now
it's effectively a highly politicized
rag that you know still has high
production values and so people still
take it seriously
um but what I wanted to get at with the
doctors is I think the most
brilliant and diabolical move of the
public health authorities
involved getting the doctors to very
publicly speak as one at the very
beginning of the uh vaccine rollout in
other words
the way doctoring is supposed to work
information accumulates clinically right
doctors see patients they if they're any
good they cannot help but notice
patterns and by getting the doctors on
the record
effectively challenging any claim that
there was a pattern of Adverse Events
before that pattern would have come
through their office right by getting
the doctors to do that somehow it made
it very hard for those doctors to
reverse course
and part of the part of the way that was
done
was by giving it to the doctors first
it was by giving it to the doctors and
all the other Health Care Professionals
first and this was you know I had I had
one Doctor Who did end up taking and
being glad that he took the vaccine but
early on he was like what are they doing
why like we can't know why why would you
put the entire Health Care
Force Workforce at risk with a new
experimental treatment first and you
know I don't know the answer to that but
I do know that one of the side effects
perhaps intentional at least by some was
exactly this now that it's all of you
who've taken it and it's your job to
make sure that everyone else takes it
you have some complaints or what because
you you're already dosed up yeah which
is not true and actually there's a uh
that's not true uh that you're already
dosed up this is a I think that this is
a
a
intuitive and wrong perspective that has
lots of people failing to realize where
they are in this program in other words
there is a dose-dependent relationship
we can see it to some extent already in
the evidence in the data there's a
dose-dependent relationship between
um these especially the MRNA vaccines
and the hazard and therefore the more
you have the more integrated your risk
absolutely and this this works but still
the difference between zero and one is
um rather large right and we can see
that some sort of model is where the
fact that so few people are taking the
boosters yeah tells us that lots of
people have updated something in their
model whether they've become agnostic
about the whole thing and they're in
their minds procrastinating and you know
they just haven't gotten it yet or
whatever they're doing something is
protecting them from getting further
doses even though they haven't stated
you know what I used to think X and now
I don't because and that's the thing
we're waiting for right like it's it's
those sorts of
admission makes it sound too onerous
right but
honesty be honest with yourself and then
share that Honesty at least with the
people whom you shamed and debilitated
at least share your your newfound
honesty with those uh
for whom you're being wrong had a direct
negative effect and you you know I you
won't know till you do it if it's not
something that you're used to doing you
won't know until you do it but you will
feel so much better right it's not easy
to say hey I really screwed this up I
thought I had it right but it's really
not easy to say but you will just
viscerally feel a huge weight off your
shoulders in doing it and by and large
you know
the game theory says it's all about the
future always it can never be about
anything else and so the point is when
you say to somebody even somebody who
even if you've been terrible to somebody
because you were absolutely sure that
they had fallen down the conspiracy
theory Rabbit Hole whatever that means
right
you may have been terrible to somebody
and if you say look
I screwed it up here's how but I
understand that I did I feel bad about
it I won't do it again right if you say
that to somebody it is not in their
interest to say well I don't accept your
apology you know there's nothing you can
do to mend this in general especially if
you have a relationship that has content
that goes beyond whatever took place
over covid people will forgive you
people will be decent to you and you
will just simply not have to live with
that fear of you know what happens if it
emerges
well so the idea of people will be
decent to you though those of us who
have been you know vilified and you know
we have been quite lucky
we haven't lost
people or jobs or
you've been told to stand outside on
Christmas and such as many people have
uh
those of us on that side of the things
are not the ones who aren't being decent
right
um but one thing that I hear and what
you're saying that I that I hope is true
but I'm not sure it is
the kind of heartfelt I looked inside of
myself I'm seeing the New Evidence
and I I behaved badly and I was wrong
that hopefully can help rebuild trust
but one of the things that has frayed
and decayed and in some cases it's
irreparable is trust between people
and so again
um from conversations I had this last
week
what I'm hearing from people
who have not been apologized to who have
lost relationships who have lost
livelihoods all of this
but one thing I'm hearing from them is
I don't know
I don't know if I want the relationships
back
because I won't ever trust them again
and it's not about it's not about like I
won't trust them because they hurt me
but specifically the thing that was said
and I heard this on more than one
occasion was
I gave them what I knew about what the
evidence was and they still vaccinated
their children
I don't trust them I will never trust
them with my children again
and like what
what do you do
well I don't know what you do no
I'm afraid we all do and it's built in
the the real thing hinges on the
distinction between a pro forma or
hedging apology and a real one
and the reason that it hinges on that is
not some touchy-feely thing
a real apology in which the person has
done the accounting of their own
wrongdoing is the insurance that makes
them safe to deal with going forward
perfectly safe No but none of us are
perfectly safe
so what there's a there's a there's a
principle right at the point that a
company
has had a major Scandal what was it I'm
not going to mention the brand because
I'm not 100 certain of it I've forgotten
but there was a tire company that had
covered up the fact that there were
blowouts that had killed a number of
people right yep
um the point is in the aftermath of that
scandal
there's actually a degree of safety in
buying those tires because of all
companies that company cannot afford to
have the pattern continue and so you
would expect extra vigilance in fact you
would expect that that company might be
willing to take a loss on each tire in
order to ensure that it was clear that
this pattern had gone away the extra
scrutiny from the public because of past
wrongs will will make for extra
vigilance on the part of the company
right so what I would say is and in my
personal policy which I have I have said
before is
um
foreign
of what you did wrong if it really is
complete is sufficient now there are
people here who I believe committed
knowing wrongs who can't apologize and
never will because to do so would be
effectively to confess to crimes I I
think you're talking a different level
though this is this is funny though
because you know having just spent time
with that transcript from almost 10
months ago I feel like we're having that
conversation again at some level
and um
the the issue
is not so much
did they see that it like even someone
who says oh wow oh I see now I shouldn't
have had my children vaccinated with
these vaccines with these ones uh I
won't do that again
even that
leaves open the reality
like it doesn't change the reality that
you were the sort of person and you know
the one I was talking this one
particular conversation she invoked my
my mama Bear's piece and substance she
said
she said to me
you
my once dear friend by the sort of
person
who gave up being a mama bear
and trusted someone who'd already lied
to you and let them have your children
I can't trust you with my children ever
again if you do that I don't care what
kind of apology you make I don't care if
you know that you were wrong the fact is
there's something in your head
there's something in their head that
allowed you to sacrifice your children
and no apologies changes that look I I
get it
on the other hand a full apology would
involve the recognition which is very
hard to reach that you put your own
children in danger because you trusted
something that you knew you should have
known better than to trust right so the
point is if somebody said that to you
like I can't believe that I allowed my
children
to be vaccinated in this way when you
know I was being told hey even if these
vaccines work the risk goes up the
younger you are and the risk of covid is
spectacularly low right right if
somebody says hey I now get that that
message was available to me at the time
and I allowed myself to be blinded and
it had a it placed it my kids in danger
right if somebody said that then the
point is How likely is it that somebody
who has had to wrestle with the terrible
knowledge that they put their own
children in danger uh is going to
blindly do that again and if they did
start to blindly do that again and you
said Hey do you remember that time
that you took this I but I I feel like
you often say to me no their minds
aren't like that right and I think you
know the 15 years that we spent really
teaching college students like actually
really getting to know 25 50 75 students
really well over the course of a quarter
or two or a full Academic Year or more
who gave us both the sense of like
almost everyone's reachable almost
everyone's alive in there and um has is
is waiting if they haven't already
discovered it
um to be sparked into creativity and
productivity and invention and Discovery
and exploration and so many interesting
things it was the very rare student even
at this really not Elite College who
wasn't couldn't couldn't be inspired
into doing some interesting work and yet
and yet we see it's like the population
level where we don't you know we don't
know any of these people we don't have
access to them and their individual
Minds on you know a daily basis for
weeks on end or months or even years
that people are making decisions not
based on but why do you think that okay
tell me okay let me give you why you
shouldn't be thinking that way or why
you think I shouldn't be thinking this
way without access to them at that level
it looks like it's not a model it's just
a conclusion no no look I think you're
mixing two things a I disagree with you
that almost everybody is reachable I
think almost everybody starts
outreachable but but in college
classrooms people were young enough that
it felt like hey they were young enough
B because you were in my classes were so
oversubscribed and they tended to be
over subscribed because students who had
gotten a lot out of it told other
students who would get a lot the college
wasn't selective but our classes were
our classes were selective and uh you
know I am I do believe that we are all
born in a condition where we can unless
you're unless you're broken you you can
be reached early but then you lose that
capacity
um but there's no there's not a boundary
but it's it it's a slope right yeah and
so my point is not hey everybody who did
wrong here can apologize and we could be
back to zero my point is the people who
are capable of delivering the necessary
apology can be made safe because the
whole point is it's the self accounting
that allows you to deliver an apology
that doesn't have any you know gray
areas or you know places to hide uh some
kind of self-deception the full
accounting that says here's how I got it
this wrong is itself a demonstration
that the person has updated their model
either that or they have to be
diabolical and willing to say this and
not believe it and not care which is
very few people
I guess I think there's a third category
and I'm not sure
um I hope I'm wrong
um but as I heard it you just described
an apology that involves a description
of the way of the ways that a person was
wrong
uh inherently is either a company is an
update in uh the reliability of their
decision making in the future
or they're diabolical and they are
reporting something that doesn't
correspond to a change in the way that
they're going to behave in the future I
think unfortunately that there are a
whole lot of people
who in order to like I just want this
relationship back oh can we just do like
family thing family holidays again okay
you know what I thought about it I saw
you were wrong I mean
I fear that that's what people are
actually thinking but like I thought
about it I see that we were lied to and
I made the wrong decision and you know
here is why but here's why I won't do it
again and yeah I'm making like a
caricature of it I'm kind of rolling my
eyes but I feel like there's people who
can deliver an apparently good apology
who will be internally kind of like oh
this is pro forma but I gotta get
through it because I really like this
person oh yeah I really like my sister I
really like my cousin I really like my
friend from high school I really like I
want I need it's my work buddy it's my
boss I gotta just do it and okay are we
good I'm really sorry okay good let's go
have a beer and I feel like there's a
lot of those people yeah and I'm worried
about them because I feel like they're
obviously from the past three years
hiding in plain sight well
I am not arguing that somebody who
delivers an apology necessarily deserves
a a clear cleaning of the Slate my point
is a proper apology that involves a
self-accounting that did not do the
following thing the accounting you are
afraid of and I also agree it uh
it is there to be feared is the
accounting that says what is the minimum
I have to acknowledge in order to get
past this right the grudging apology the
minimal apology that thing is strategic
and it is it is functioning to preserve
the capacity to do similar things in the
future I want no part of it even if that
none of that is conscious right whatever
mechanism it is it says I really I want
to get past this and you know you can
hear people who are actually good at
apologizing you will hear they are not
monitoring whether this is enough for
you to let them off the hook what they
are trying to do is tell you their own
argument with themselves here I'm angry
at myself here's what for yeah here's
what it looks like inside and I'm just
going to talk I'm going to let you see
that and then you're going to decide if
that's if that covers what you saw right
and you may say actually it doesn't I
hear what you what what you're doing
there you have found this seven things
that you did wrong but you've missed
these other two yeah like think on it
some more and then come back to me right
yeah and hopefully really we've all been
there on both sides like if we're adults
past you know the age of I don't even
know what but you know we presumably all
of us have
done done wrong unto others and had
wrongs done unto us that warranted
complex apologies and sometimes uh the
difficult conversation that happens does
involve it like exactly what you just
said
yeah you've got some of it but you don't
know all of it that's not enough
him go back go back think more come back
to me after you have and if they do yeah
right then what you have is somebody who
is now
hyper conscious of this Hazard that
exists in them that's the point is that
if you do this properly then you end up
conscious of things that most people are
not fully conscious of and so if you how
often does this even like you and I do
this with each other
we do yep and I think the audience
if you're watching
part of what you're watching for is
because you can tell that we do yep that
we are actually honest with one another
and it's not that
we're always prayed for one another at
all but we have we have both been on
both sides of that yep okay with each
other
have I been with other people I don't
know
like so we are lucky to have in our
lives each other with whom we can do
that with and with whom we do
I don't know that most people have
someone
with whom they can do that that it
wouldn't
just tear apart the fabric of the thing
and
it
disappears into the wind yeah I mean
I mean this goes to a different
conversation that we've had uh multiple
times here which is not so much here
this being the permanent temporary
permanent oh no permanent we have never
had this conversation here because this
is the first conversation we've had here
but in the past on Dark Horse we have
talked about the painful upgrade to
one's uh
friend group that occurs in crisis
because people disappoint you and
they're actually telling you something
that you need to know they're not up to
the challenge of being you know they can
be a friend under
simple conditions but if a friend who
cannot be a friend under difficult
conditions isn't really a friend and so
you lose those people and you gotta not
do everything to get them back because
if they're not capable of at least
apologizing for what they actually did
wrong then it's not really uh it's it's
not something to invest in but the other
thing is that people surprise you in the
other direction and you encounter these
folks who you didn't know before who are
up to that challenge and so I'm not
telling you that the world is going to
be full of people who are capable of
delivering a high quality apology and
deserve the Forgiveness that comes from
it but I'm telling you that that's the
thing you're on the lookout for and to
the extent that you encounter people who
do that
um I think it makes total sense to put
them in a very different category than
you would put somebody
who has not made eye contact with where
they've been
yeah but yes yes I agree with you no but
I guess
no a butt which is that
one of the things I saw this week one of
the reasons I started thinking about
certainty was
I see
I see no
holes I see no tatters in the shield of
certainty that the people who have
accepted
pronouncements from on high since the
beginning of this thing have
if anything they're more entrenched than
ever
well and they're more self-satisfied
than ever and they're more eager to
laugh at those of us who don't agree
with them than ever
so
yeah I want I want those people with
like with the with the real soul
searching and the real apologies
uh to to start coming forward but
you know it's it's like the entire world
is now politics
no I mean
everything is politicized by some Force
yeah
um but it doesn't own everyone and you
know you said something in your your
setup here
about the tendency if you were to look
at the group of people who's certain in
One Direction versus people who are
certain in the other direction
it was an evolutionary process in One
Direction and absolutely not in the
other
um and this I think is key right the
fact if you haven't spent time if you
haven't decamped from your position and
seen the other side then you don't
really know how deeply you believe it
and in fact who is it Hume who
formalizes this principle
he uh who cannot
articulate the other's position uh knows
little of his own or something like this
that sounds potentially humey I don't
know yeah uh it's definitely humorous
but um not really that humorous no but
anyway uh the point the point is when
you have an asymmetry like this where
one side gains
people over time right you've got two
sides that are claiming some something
is inevitable that's another prediction
then right there right so you know I
I said the level of certainty has
changed on one side and not on the other
and and the second prediction here that
you are making is one of the sides is
um gaining people on the other side the
prediction is is going to be losing them
yep so and we know they are because
people have actually gotten vaccine
injured for instance how many people do
you know who
um started out thinking these so-called
vaccines were dangerous and now think
they're safe right that's that's the
first yeah like if it doesn't it's not a
known category for a reason and it's
because the evidence I mean there were
people like like the doctor I referred
to who was like ah why don't do this
like you had to wait a little bit and I
was like okay
I'm not I'm now going to take it
okay well but then that goes to the
point that you and I were disagreeing on
which is the difference between safety
and harm
yep right that's right and so I would
only use a different analogy than I've
used in the past you know uh is it safe
to get in your car drunk and drive home
no does that mean you're going to crash
nope you could get home absolutely
unscathed right so the point is harm and
safety are two different things we
understand the difference very easily
yeah and no and I and and you're right
that it's important like you to say that
you weren't harmed it doesn't mean that
it was safe like this and I I feel like
that's a formulation that I immediately
grok and that I think almost everyone
would too you can say just because just
because I wasn't harmed doesn't mean it
was a safe thing to do whereas looking
at it on the prospective side is harder
to to distinguish between the two right
well people you know this is the the
problem of the bluntness of language
that comes from us all using a shared
glossary that we you know some of us use
things very precisely we're very
technical about it and we mean only what
it is that we intend to imbue into those
words and other people just sort of hear
it Loosely and so the idea of you know
is is that pharmaceutical safe right
well you know if you talk to me you're
talking to somebody who's spent an awful
lot of time thinking about how
Pharmaceuticals might be unsafe on the
basis that we have test animals that
don't tell you what it is that test
animals are supposed to tell you right
so you're getting a technical uh
response rather than a you know safety
harm what's the difference yeah right
um
yeah
sorry I've lost there was some other
threat I wanted to follow there but um
well we could uh switch gears a little
bit if you're if unless you want sure no
I mean to try to prompt you to think
about what the thread was I guess there
was one more one more piece which has to
do and this is this is my own soul
searching here
I think when I hear you talk about this
and I hear you talk about the anger of
people
I
check with myself to see whether I'm
angry
and then I find something funny that I
can't quite figure out I know it's real
but I don't know what it means
there's some way in which
I know myself to be angry at certain
people who did not do well by us in the
circumstance but I don't feel the anger
it's like some part of me feels it and
then my conscious mind is shielded from
it
and I have a feeling that that's serving
a purpose but there are things you can
do if the emotion doesn't penetrate to
the part of your mind that decides how
to act yeah and presumably there's also
a huge cost to that you know anger
didn't evolve for no reason at all Angry
evolved for a very good reason and so
there are places where you want to be
able to keep it absolutely in check so
that it cannot drive your behavior and
there are other places where it is
important that it be seen and I think
probably
um
whatever
for whatever reason I am constructed in
the odd way that I'm constructed
I'm paying one one cost in order to get
to some benefit and you know I saw this
in one other place that wasn't about
anger
um there are two places in the Evergreen
story where I run into the same
observation about myself
one is that initial confrontation
outside my class the one that got
captured and the one that put me in the
public eye
I remember that interaction I remember
feeling my leg shake
as if there was
I don't know fear or a very strong
emotion of some kind but I remember
thinking that's odd that my leg is
shaking because that's not how I feel
right so I think some part of me felt it
and some other part of me didn't and the
part that didn't was the part that was
talking to the students which was very
effective you know people say to me
about that scene they say
I couldn't have done it okay right
um and I think the point is oh that's
because there's some circuitry that uh
blocks some
emotion from rising to some level
um of feeling the other place is
when I had tried to go to school on my
bike and I had run into evidence that I
was being ambushed in some sense that
there were students waiting for me in a
place where I was known to go and I
deviated and I went to the police
station and I talked to Stacy Brown the
police chief and she said I don't think
you're imagining it go home and get off
your bike because we can't protect you
you report that when I came through the
door that I appeared shaken like you've
never seen me shaken yeah I don't
remember being faken
I remember thinking I can't believe this
is happening to me in 2017 in my own
neighborhood in the United States you
know this thing
I was going to say that's written in
literature which no you don't you know
the way that people describe people
who've been really scared or traumatized
is having like an ashen face or a gray
face yeah and I whenever I read that
description I think I don't what what
but that's the thing that that's what I
saw in you that it was like just the
color was gone and it wasn't bloodless
it was it was just
you looked like you were almost in black
and white
yeah it's funny because I think I was
having
um
I was having an analytical response
which was
what does it mean to be hunted in your
own neighborhood and have the police
told they can't intervene
what has to be true in history where are
you in history when that happens to you
right and so that was like
um
a
huge mental update and it's one you know
it's an update I haven't gone back I
believe that that's where we are in
history
um
but the emotional part of it
didn't even get recorded yeah right I
didn't I don't think I felt it in some
sense and I don't remember it
um but you clearly knew you saw it
yeah I'm not sure that I would remember
I mean you
I said it to you and you recall it to me
enough times now that it you know it I
now have a very clear memory of the
memory at least so I don't know
I think that I would be remembering it
with as much acuteness because it did it
did feel at the time like it was the it
was the most X that I'd ever seen you
um but it's it's always hard to know for
sure yeah you know how many how many
layers of memory on memory are you
making and
to what degree are you now buying your
own story
well I guess uh I'm not I'm talking
about me yeah yeah you know I got that
um I do wonder you know you and I have
recognized that I have some
severe deficits with respect to uh
normal functioning in the modern world
keeping track of stuff right time the
time for example
um and that in emergency circumstances
the opposite seems to be true all right
I wonder if this thing isn't related to
that I think it is yeah I mean I think
it almost has to be
I think it is
all right you're gonna switch gears oh
boy it's okay okay switch screws into
reverse then
um
this is just a little I've got two other
things one of which is kind of related
one of which is not related at all we're
going to end by talking about cats and
language and people
okay a little piece of research that
came out uh that's kind of fun
uh and you might want to talk about
something but
one of the things
that
I was reminded of in Portland this week
which I am gratefully not reminded of
here on our new island home in the San
Juans
in Far Northwest Washington State
um is that so much of what is happening
in cities is the celebration and
promotion of mental illness and
addiction
and
you know schellenberger's book San
Francisco
does an amazing job actually of
describing the various the various ways
that people end up living on the streets
and talk he talks specifically about
what a
what a sleight of hand what you know a
kind of a diabolical sleight of hand it
is to just be like well they're homeless
that's what that category is it's
homeless because that then allows people
many of whom are you know
well-intentioned but wrong to say well
if your problem is homelessness then
what you need is a home right and so you
know ah then we have all these things
springing up all these organizations
bringing up like what we need to do is
like you can't do anything about any of
this until you have a home for them like
that's the only solution it's like
actually there's a lot of categories of
people who are living on the streets and
some of them are not
down on many of them are not down on
their luck had a series of bad events
happen to them and maybe a couple of bad
decisions but are really working hard to
get themselves off the streets that is
not the description for most of the
people I'm seeing on the streets in
Portland at this point right
um too much of it is at least partially
facultative
by choice and too much of it may have
started that way and then it's
compounded by mental illness by
addiction
um and you know the way to deal with
drug addicts passed out on the streets
with their pants around their ankles is
not to gently ask something like cleaner
surroundings in which to get high that's
not it that's that's that's not how you
do it
uh and similarly the way to deal with
anxiety is not to encourage and promote
it and uh I
was thinking about going into whole riff
about Willamette Week I don't know that
we really wanted to that so Willamette
Week is the
um Portland's free news weekly of the
sort of which exists in many many big
cities La reader Seattle
uh no no no what Katie Herzog used to
work for
can't think of what the Seattle one is
called anyway
um I'm sure there will be people in the
chat who
figure it out or Zach's about to figure
it out
um the the free news weekly is a thing
and it's always been you know pretty
left-wing and it always it used to have
um
you know sex ads on the back pages
um but it always has like in the last
third or half is like what's happening
in the city this week here's you know
here's the Live Events here's the music
Here's you know here's here's where to
go here's the things that are happening
and I when we first moved to Portland I
started donating to them on a monthly
basis I love a good free news weekly and
then they just took aiming us they
totally went after us really despicable
and our book and I don't know I just I
stopped giving them money at that point
yeah that was uh at least defensible I
mean it wasn't a Make It or Break It for
them I hope level of money but
for God's sake after you figure it out
Seattle it's a stranger that's right
um that's that's the Seattle version of
Willamette Week in Portland
anyway I will say that as Despicable as
they became
I went looking I picked up
I have here the most recent I can't even
find it now uh yeah this is the most
recent Willamette Week from this week
that I just picked up when I was in town
and uh
and
I looked at their endorsements also for
the election and because I'm a little
shocked
that they are doing a much better job of
being careful
than they have been and the easiest
example to use here is
Portland of course has been managed
completely god-awfully for you know
through covet and you know presumably
before that then uh as well but that has
been particularly revealing and one of
the things one of the ways that it has
been driven into the ground is by the
city councilman person woman city
councilwoman Joanne Hardesty
completely awful like really made so
many bad decisions managed to get the
police defunded before finally it was
not totally defunded but largely
defunded and then the funds were
ultimately returned at the point that
the homicide rate spiked like you know
all of the stupid things that we're
hearing about
um largely those policies were coming
from her and then they were adopted by
city council she was the city councilman
and in May of this year Well we endorsed
her in the city council race
and there were lots of people running
and in the primary uh to uh to people
who got the most votes such that they
were in the election this last week
which was Joanne Hardesty and Renee
Gonzalez who we actually had the Good
Fortune to meet at an event back I don't
even know
right I guess before the primary
sometimes so in May or something of this
year April and May of this year and he
seemed great
and he indeed
um became her only contender in the
election and Willamette Week switched
their endorsement and they actually
wrote an explanation of why and said
Hardesty is no longer the right person
for Portland
um she has demonstrated that she is not
doing what's right for Portland and they
endorsed Gonzalez and Gonzalez actually
won like he and and good for Portland
like there's a whole lot not going on
right for Portland right now but
congratulations Renee like that's
awesome a sign of hope it is a sign of
hope uh and it was also a sign of hope
when I saw that and there was a number
of other things in Willamette Week that
I thought huh
maybe they're getting a clue that would
be awesome that would also help because
that is of course uh a publication that
is read by the most entrenched so the
people who are least likely to have
models of what their opinions are as
opposed to having received wisdom from
on high which in some cases might people
haven't weak I look forward to their
apology
to us you mean yeah yeah that would be
a number of them are due in fact yes
so
all that said which is my like oh
actually cool keep on doing that however
uh they're still publishing Comics like
this one Zach which I hope you have
ready uh called anxiety garden and I'll
just read it for those who are listening
and not watching the the the the comic
widely more widely is called anxiety
Garden so right there you know something
about it it says hi I'm Alicia which is
also the name of the person who creates
anxiety Garden hi I'm Alicia you know
the pandemic has been long and hard
but did you know it's not over
and the longer we pretend it is the
longer immunocompromised people like me
are stuck in limbo so keep masking and
getting vaxed or else
I don't really know how to take that
so I went to this person's website
and this person's website describes them
as Alicia Gatlin is a queer disabled
non-binary comic artist making scenes
about rheumatoid arthritis mental health
and Niche interests
why are we letting
the uninvestigated and wrong conclusions
of those who are celebrating their own
anxiety
Drive people's sense of what makes sense
at an individual and public health level
why would we do that why would we let
the anxious Drive policy the anxious are
specifically anxious
which is getting in their way of making
sound decisions for themselves and
others
so I want to link this up to where you
started yes it does like I just didn't
quite see the way that shoehorned it in
so go for it so there's a
short circuit there are certain
categories that we are now told we are
morally deficient if we don't feel a
particular way about them right it's
nonsense this is not how feeling a
particular way about things actually
works but we are told that you have to
feel this way about people who entertain
hypotheses of collusion right so you
have to feel this way about people who
are hesitant about so-called vaccines
right you have to feel this way about
people who uh you know throw some
women's clothing and want to go into
women's bathroom this way about Ukraine
this way about January 6th this way
about Trump this way about everything
and so it's the hijacking of a
superficial model of the world right how
should you feel about people who suffer
from anxiety well I should feel
compassionate towards them yes okay does
that mean that I am required to like a
cartoon from their perspective that ends
on a note that it threatens people who
don't have this anxiety in fact attempts
to induce anxiety into them and that and
for people who come to a different
conclusion and frankly the right
conclusion about whether or not everyone
doing this thing that they want you to
do is actually going to help them right
it's not buddy to answer your question
why are we letting blank yes
if you are a news weekly like Willamette
Week and you have a piece of your layout
to spare for such an exercise then all
of the people who feel obligated to have
a particular reaction to it tell
themselves oh that was a good cartoon or
I'm glad that was there or whatever it
is they tell themselves and it is the
exact equivalent
of people remember how comedy became
really really unfunny and you could kind
of tell it had become really really
unfunny because what people were doing
was they were applauding the laugh lines
rather than laughing at them
right the point is that that's good I
haven't noticed that thing that's right
it's that same thing so you imagine that
this comic which isn't funny and by the
way is threatening threatening yep right
um
causes people to do the equivalent of
applaud
something that they don't really believe
in because the point is the Applause is
about I'm signing to that you know are
you an anti-vaxxer no I'm signing on to
these vaccines that kind of thing right
um so that reflexive View and this is
actually the same thing it took me a
long time to understand it but it's the
same thing as this business with the
term homelessness yes right the point is
homelessness is a symptom
right
and it is
no better no more useful a description
of the population that finds themselves
yes without a home amongst many other
things right it is a bit like you know
you've got somebody and they've fallen
off a boat and they are beginning to
succumb to the waves and you diagnose
them with pneumonia because they've got
fluid in their lungs right it's like no
they're drowning get them antibiotics
right exactly throwing antibiotics off
the back of the boat at this drowning
person is not a useful remedy any more
than giving these people homes is a
useful remedy because it doesn't address
the core problem right
um and so anyway if you look up the dog
with my cry for antibiotics right no you
don't have to take any oh you don't but
one of the chats that the dog would wake
up from what he made a bad argument oh
no
that's awesome he knows that was a good
argument that was no no my argument give
him antibiotics oh give me oh there you
go all right I think yeah yeah so anyway
I guess the idea is how many years did I
hear the term homelessness and not
question it right
right I used to well it did it didn't it
was a different population in the 70s
and 80s it was it was I'm not sure I
mean you know we know that a lot of
homelessness actually was the result of
you know reagan-era policies that
emptied you know asylums of people who
didn't have the mental capacity to hold
down a job they were struggling with
mental illness and so the point is
their homelessness is no more
homelessness than it is
institutionlessness right the point is
they were
kicked out of Institutions that had
taken I'm not having presumably being at
maybe not kicked out but the people who
ended up in institutions not everyone
but many of them their families were
like I would sound I can't do I like I I
this this person has a condition which
renders them uncontrollable by me in my
home even though I love them or I'm
trying to love them and therefore they
need to go there and then to have them
released onto the streets like well
that's gonna work great so this all all
that we have talked about today raises a
question
that has
it's been bothering me for many many
years and in fact it started bothering
me over respiratory illnesses long
before there was coveted
which is there is no good guidance on
what we collectively are supposed to do
about a respiratory illness right
if you think there is good guys oh
you're not supposed to go to work well
do the labor laws protect you for not
going to work when you have it do we
have some way of demonstrating that you
have such a thing and so that we know
that we are collectively better off of
you don't go to work because you might
spread it to 50 people while you're
there no if you think there's good
guidance where's the threshold are you
supposed to not go to work for a cold
arguably we shouldn't go to work with a
cold but then you would have it if you
don't have sick leave and you're working
an hourly hourly wage right you know so
the point is we there is no guidance on
yes we are not supposed to go to work
when we have an infectious disease that
we might communicate to others that we
have contact with in the course of our
work right there is no guidance you are
supposed to infer something that is
incompatible between your responsibility
to other people and your responsibility
not to lose your job your responsibility
to your family to keep the roof over
their heads potentially to your employer
as well with regard to like I'm on
Deadline I got to get the thing done
whatever it is right and covet actually
began it did terrible job of it but it
began to have a discussion how are how
is this disease spread finally we're
going to talk about that are we right
what are you supposed to do if you have
it what are you supposed to do if you've
contacted somebody who had it and you
don't yet have any symptoms right all of
these things are you know there's some
question yes is it communicated by
people who don't have symptoms now I
still don't think that that's as clear
as people have come to imagine right
we're supposed to believe that it
transmits without symptoms there's
something a little suspicious about that
idea because symptoms are in fact
largely due to the mechanisms that
pathogens use to transmit themselves
point of order a lot suspicious about
that idea a lot of suspicions but
nonetheless were you to imagine in one
of the many multiverses
no okay
um imagine sometime in the future after
our species has gone extinct and been
replaced by another thing imagine in
some other version of the Multiverse
public health does not suck and what it
does is it studies the way disease
actually transmits it puts forward that
information and then experts who are
actually expert in something discuss
what the best
policy is with respect to a cost benefit
analysis that is made explicit in other
words we're not going to get an
infectious disease to zero right have
you become a utopian then no I I am
I'm a Believer in something which
um I I don't want to use too many
technical terms but you might call it
good governance and no I haven't seen it
in a very long time if ever but but the
potential existence potential exists but
it needs to exist
it does and this you know and this is
what the game Beat Movement is about how
could you uh how could you jump start
good governance in a context where bad
governance has so much power
yeah yeah all right I'm I'm back from
the Multiverse I'm not a Believer for
those of you who are feverishly writing
angry letters
um I I don't believe I do believe in a
very small amount of free will I don't
believe in the Multiverse and uh
um it's like it's a big reveal party
here today what else and I don't believe
we're living in a simulation but I do
believe there are two pieces of evidence
that go in the other direction maybe
we'll talk about that next week Oh I
thought you were going to say you don't
think we're living in a simulation but
we you do think we're brains and jars I
am not
the rest of you that's that's between
you and your God so our cats are on walk
about this week and maybe since I have
something specifically to talk about
with regard to cats and some research uh
maybe we should do that next week when
our cats hopefully will not be unlocked
we'll not be out maybe we should save
the the cat's language and and person
discussion so that they can win for next
week there is a there is
yeah there's a there's an awesome end
point that I'm just not going to give
away
yeah all right you feel confident of
this because my as you know I don't even
think the cats know their names so I
know their ability to uh have any
opinion whatsoever on the rest of what
you have to say we've been at it for a
while it's a totally different thing
than anything we've been doing and it
would be nice to have cats in frame when
talking about cats yes we should talk in
front of their backs not behind them
if
all right so I'm glad we've agreed on
something that's all right start
um I think I mean I don't even know when
we started because we had so many
technical difficulties but I think we've
been going on for a while yeah but Zach
also can't tell us
an hour and 47 minutes
and yeah well I think it's it's getting
late here we're still going to do a q a
yep so we're going to stop this uh for
this week we will be back same time same
place next week hopefully with better
everything and more cats and
um if you are with us live right now you
can stick with us give us a 15 minute
break or so or however long it takes and
we'll be back with the live q a you can
ask your questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com uh any logistical
questions
um you can send to darker's moderator
gmail.com not questions that you want us
to address on air that's again
darkhorsesmissions.com consider joining
our patreons going to Natural Selections
and read my sub stack read 100 gatherers
Guide to the 21st century if you like
the kind of thinking that we're
deploying here and
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside hang in there we're
bound to hit bottom at some point
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]